WE'LL HAVE A LOT MORE LATER
ON THE SHOW WITH THAT BUT,
FIRST, WITH THE DETAILS FROM
HIS BREAKING NEWS REPORT IS
THE HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S START AT THE BEGINNING
HERE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THESE ISSUES BUT
TONIGHT'S NEWS IS DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOW
DISCOVERED A LONG EMAIL
CHAIN.
IS THAT A PROPER WAY TO
CHARACTERIZE IT.
>> THAT'S HOW IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED TO ME THAT'S
CORRECT, SEAN.
>> Sean: JUST TO GET IT SET
UP, WHOSE NAMES ARE ON THIS
EMAIL CHAIN.
>> I'M TOLD JAMES COMEY IS
ONE OF THEM PEOPLE FROM THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THAT
THERE ARE KEY PLAYERS THAT
WERE THE OBVIOUS PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE FBI.
I DON'T HAVE THEIR NAMES,
WORKING AT VARIOUS POINTS ON
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
SO IT'S A LARGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO GET READY
TO GET THIS FISA WARRANT
SUBMITTED TO THE COURT AND
THERE ARE TWO OR THREE VERY
IMPORTANT REVELATIONS.
ONE IS THAT JAMES COMEY IS
INVOLVED IN DISCUSSIONS.
TWO, THERE IS MENTION IN
THESE EMAILS THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
POSSIBLY THE NSA OR ANOTHER
AGENCY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
THE QUALITY OF THE
INTELLIGENCE IN THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
AND, THREE, THAT THERE WERE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WORRIES,
CONCERNS THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HAD ALREADY BEGUN
TALKING TO THE NEWS MEDIA.
THIS IS BEFORE THEY FILED A
FISA WARRANT, BEFORE THEY
FIRE HIM.
IF ALL THOSE THINGS ARE
TRUE, IF THE FBI HAD NOT
CORROBORATED AND THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STEELE
DOSSIER, IF THEY KNEW THAT
STEELE HAD TALKED TO YAHOO
NEWS AND YAHOO NEWS HAS USED
AS A CORROBORATING PIECE OF
EVIDENCE FOR THE DOSSIER,
THESE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES
THAT WOULD BE MISLEADING THE
COURT WITH THIS INFORMATION
BY PORTRAYING IT AS
SOMETHING MORE SOLID THAN IT
IS.
YOU KNOW, WE LEARNED ALL
ABOUT THIS FROM TWO
APPEARANCES ON FOX NEWS OVER
THE HOLIDAY WEEK.
DEVIN NUNES SHOWED UP ON
MARIA BALTIMORE'S SHOW AND
YOUR SHOW AND HE SAID HEY I
AMENDED MY REQUEST FOR THE
DECLASSIFICATION.
NO ONE FOLLOWED UP.
WE STARTED OF REQUESTING
QUESTIONS AND WE FOLLOWED UP
THERE IS EMAIL TRAIL AND MAY
BE SOME OF THE MORE DAMNING
AND BELATED PRODUCED
EVIDENCE THAT MAY SUGGEST
WRONGDOING AT THE FBI.
>> Sean: LET'S GO THROUGH
THIS SLOWLY.
>> SURE.
>> Sean: WE HAVE EVIDENCE
THAT YOU HAVE UNCOVERED
EMAIL CHAINS FROM THE PEOPLE
AT THE FBI AND DOJ WHO ARE
AT THE TOP LEVELS.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS
THAT THEY KNEW THAT THIS WAS
NOT VERIFIED, THIS DOSSIER.
THEY KNEW THAT -- THEY KNEW
WHERE IT CAME FROM, THAT
HILLARY HAD PAID FOR IT THEY
NEVER TOOK THE TIME TO
VERIFY IT THEMSELVES.
>> AND RATHER THAN DO THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE, THEY WENT
ALONG AND JUST DECIDED THAT
THEY WANTED TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT AND THEY COMMITTED
WHAT IS ULTIMATELY A
CONSCIOUS FRAUD ON THE COURT
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION?
>> THAT'S THE QUESTION AND
ALLEGATION THAT HAS TO BE
FURTHER INVESTIGATED.
UNTIL WE SEE THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE OF THIS EMAIL I
DON'T WANT TO PASS JUDGMENT.
I CAN TELL YOU PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SEEN IT OR BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THAT EMAIL SAY
DIRECTLY IT'S AMONGST THE
MOST DAMNING EVIDENCE OF
WRONGDOING BY THE FBI.
IF THOSE PEOPLE SEE IT, AND
IF DEVIN NUNES THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO BOTHER THE
EVIDENCE AND ASK HIM TO
DECLASSIFY IT AMONG THE
OTHER DOCUMENTS I THINK WE
SHOULD ASSUME IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF EVIDENCE.
>> Sean: HOW COULD ANYBODY
JUSTIFY NOT TELLING THE
COURT KEY PIECES OF
INFORMATION?
BEFORE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
QUOTE OF ROD ROSENSTEIN, IT
WAS BACK IN MAY WHEN HE SAID
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
FISA, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE A
CAREER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL.
AND THEY PUT THEIR
SIGNATURE, THAT'S THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIBILITY THAT
THEY ARE PUTTING BEHIND THAT
WARRANT.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: THEY NEVER VERIFIED
IT AND NOW WE KNOW THAT THEY
EVEN SUSPECTED THEMSELVES
THAT NONE OF IT WAS TRUE IN
MANY WAYS.
BUT IT NEVER STOPPED THEM
BECAUSE THEIR DESIRE TO GET
THAT WARRANT FAR EXCEEDED A
DESIRE TO DO IT IN A -- USE
THE PROPER PROCESS AND
PROCESSES AND DO DUE
DILIGENCE AND THEY WANTED IT
MORE THAN THEY WANTED TO
FOLLOW THE LAW.
AND THEY PURPOSEFULLY KEPT
INFORMATION THAT IS
PERTINENT FROM THE JUDGES.
THAT'S FAIR, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S DEFINITELY --
I THINK THAT IS NOW NOT IN
DISPUTE ANYMORE.
LET'S THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
KNOW, SEAN, FOR SURE
INDISPUTABLE.
THE CORE EVIDENCE FOR THE
FISA WARRANT.
THAT'S ANDY MCCABE'S
DESCRIPTION.
WITHOUT IT WE WOULD NOT HAVE
PURSUED THE FISA WARRANT
CAME FROM A PRODUCT PAID FOR
BY HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO TRY TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP IN THE
FINAL MONTHS OF THE
ELECTION.
WE KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
HANDLE THAT EVIDENCE
PREPARED AND TRIED TO RUSH
IT THROUGH THE FBI TO THE
COURT WERE TWO AGENTS WHO ON
THEIR OWN SAID THEY WANTED
TO STOP DONALD TRUMP FROM
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW THE PERSON WHO
CREATED THE DOSSIER DOESN'T
STAND BY IT HE SAYS HE KNEW
IT WAS UNCORROBORATED
INTELLIGENCE WHEN HE
SUBMITTED IT AND HE HIMSELF
DESPISE DONALD TRUMP AND
DESPITE ALL THAT, AND NOW
THE NSA OR SOME OTHER
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
AGENCY HAVING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DOSSIER AND THE FBI
KNOWING THE JOURNALISTS THEY
WERE GOING TO USE
CORROBORATING ALL OF THAT,
ALL OF THAT NOW IS NOT
DISPUTED AND WE THINK THIS
IS A GOOD PRODUCT.
I THINK THAT'S THE QUESTION
WE NEED TO HAVE ANSWERED.
WHY DID THIS MOVE FORWARD
WITH ALL OF THESE FLAWS?
>> Sean: THESE JUST AREN'T
FLAWS THEY KNEW IT WAS
FRAUDULENT AND THEIR DESIRE
TO GET TRUMP I WOULD ARGUE
FAR EXCEEDS IT BY OTHER
EVIDENCE.
NOW THE QUESTION IS THE
'BEFORE THE ELECTION TALKED
ABOUT UNREDACTING AND
RELEASING THE FISA
APPLICATION.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED YET.
GANG OF EIGHT INFORMATION.
THE 302S WITH BRUCE OHR AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THAT HAS
NOT HAPPENED YET.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
RECENTLY SAID I MIGHT DO IT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME IF
THIS IS THE FIGHT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS WANT
TO HAVE.
BUT THIS IS THE FOURTH
BUCKET AS WE CALL IT THAT
DEVIN NUNES WAS TALKING
ABOUT THAT EVERYBODY KNEW.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: EVERYBODY KNEW THIS
WAS PHONY -- THIS BASICALLY
THEY CREATED AND FABRICATED
A LIE AT WORST, A STORY TO
THE COURT AND WITHHELD
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION THAT
WOULD HAVE PREVENTED ANY
JUDGE FROM EVER GRANTING A
FISA WARRANT.
WHY WON'T THE PRESIDENT
RELEASE IT?
>> SO I THINK HIS LAWYERS
AND HE HAVE COME UP WITH A
PRUDENT CONCEPT.
MY REPORTING INDICATE THAT
HE IS STILL AS COMMITTED AS
EVER TO RELEASING THESE
DOCUMENTS.
LISTEN, THE FIRST THING THAT
WILL VINDICATE THE PRESIDENT
IS IF ROBERT MUELLER
FINISHES HIS INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT CHARGED
WITH ANY CRIMES, RIGHT?
HE WANTS TO GET THIS OVER
WITH.
HE IS FEARFUL AND HIS
LAWYERS ARE FEARFUL IF HE
RELEASES THE DOCUMENTS
BEFORE THEN HE WILL BE
ACCUSED OF TAMPERING OR
TRYING TO SWAY THE
INVESTIGATION AT THE LAST
MINUTE.
IT'S ON A WIND DOWN.
LET IT WIND DOWN IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS REPORTERS
ARE THINKING ACCORDING TO MY
REPORTING.
WE CAN HE HAVE THIS DEBATE
HOW B. HOW THIS THING
ORIGINATED AND HOW THE FLAWS
OCCURRED AND MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN TO SOME
OTHER PERSON IN THE FUTURE.
I THINK THAT'S THE PROCESS
HE IS FOLLOWING.